Eine sehr eigene Liebeserklärung
an den andalusischen Tanz:
Flamenco – das ist pure Weiblichkeit.
Doch hier tanzen ausschließlich Männer.
Für mich ist Tanz eine Sprache,
die keine Grenzen hat und dem Gefühl folgt
und mir ermöglicht, mich mitzuteilen.
Für mich ist das eine ehrliche Sprache.
Mit der Show „VIVA!“ feiert Manuel Liñán
die Freiheit der Bewegung
und des Ausdrucks.
Gemeinsam mit seinem männlichen
Ensemble durchbricht er dabei
die Geschlechterrollen
des traditionellen Flamenco.
Die Show hat er selbst geschrieben
und choreographiert.
Eine Szene handelt von seiner Kindheit,
als er als tanzender Junge
in Frauenkleidern ausgegrenzt wurde.
Als ich klein war,
machten sich alle über mich lustig.
Ich fühlte, dass ich nicht die Rolle erfüllte,
die gesellschaftlich von mir erwartet wurde.
Also habe ich mich
in meinem Zimmer eingeschlossen.
Und dort, in diesem kleinen Zimmer,
konnte ich meiner Vorstellung
freien Lauf lassen.
Ich konnte mich verkleiden
und mich so frei bewegen,
wie es mir draußen
als Mann verwehrt blieb.
Heute gilt Manuel Liñán als einer
der besten Flamencotänzer der Welt.
Bereits kurz nach seiner Tanzausbildung
trat er mit den renommiertesten
Ensembles des Landes auf.
Seinen Ursprung hat der Flamenco im
spanischen Andalusien des 19. Jahrhunderts.
Typisch sind die prachtvollen
und figurbetonten Kleider.
Es ist vor allem ein für Andalusien
identitätsstiftender Tanz.
Manuel Liñán erforscht
durch den Flamenco das eigene Selbst
und interpretiert den Tanz immer wieder neu
– so wie 2018 in „Baile de Autor“,
zu Deutsch „Autorentanz“.
Wie ein Magier zaubert er
Traumwelten auf die Bühne
und nimmt das Publikum auf eine Reise
durch sein Unterbewusstsein mit.
Dass er immer wieder bewusst
mit den Geschlechterrollen bricht
und damit provoziert,
bringt ihm Anerkennung
beim Publikum und in den Kritiken.
Natürlich freut uns das.
Aber ich stelle fest, dass wir noch
einen weiten Weg vor uns haben,
bis die Gesellschaft akzeptiert,
dass jeder Mensch seine eigene Identität
und Ästhetik hat.
Da hat sich zwar schon etwas getan,
aber der Weg ist noch sehr weit.
Tanz als Appell für mehr Toleranz:
Den Anfang für eine Veränderung
haben Manuel Liñán und sein Ensemble
schon mutig geschafft.